let's get into hatred mail here's a
reminder about what hatred mail is it's
like email for words from your racist
grandma on steroids patriot man written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom this
may be a first Pat for Hadrian male
riches that we have Shakespeare as a
part of Hadrian male in a way obviously
there's a broader overarching theme
which is anti-semitism and that is sort
of served by the inclusion of
Shakespeare what am I talking about take
a listen to this isn't David Pakman just
another obnoxious [ __ ] Jew never heard
of him before
dirty [ __ ] ha ha David Pakman you're
an idiot
I hope Israel becomes a multicultural
bowl - ha ha what's the plan now Jew man
so relatively short but still 3 grammar
and spelling errors that I saw [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] is a Jewish character from
Shakespeare and in the midst of
anti-intellectualism you some hike
somehow got the low information
patriotic crowd interested in something
that could maybe be considered a bit of
culture but really it was just a way to
insult Jews so I guess we figured out
patriots may overlap with Shakespeare if
it will suit their anti-semitic
priorities I mean if you wanted to
reference Shakespeare to seem esteemed
it was kind of overshadowed because he
used the wrong you're yes and also he
spell - your name incorrectly so we
don't even know if he's talking about
you that's true it could be so it could
be someone who spells their last name PA
CK ma n which is certainly not the host
of this program that's absolutely not me
remember that you can turn hatred of
Hell into something positive use the
coupon code hey tree at 40 at david
pakman.com slash membership that will
save you 40% that's a four and A zero
forty percent off of the membership of
your choice